[Musique]
bienvenue c'est le plateau d' à tanis
date à dire je reçois aujourd'hui par
skype
arielle dombasle et nicolas ker qui
sortent demain le 19 juin un nouvel
album en pire et qui seront en concert
le 17 septembre à la maroquinerie et je
recevrai ensuite pierre curie le
conservateur du musée jacquemart-andré
pour parler de l'exposition turner qui
ouvre enfin il qui durera jusqu'en
janvier
mais commençons par arielle dombasle et
nicolas ker bonjour tous les deux vous
allez bien oui oui on vous avait mis sur
des toits en isolation mais on est
heureux
la belle salle très belle d'un très beau
balcon avec avec des pointes et aiguisé
oui si jamais tout va mal on va se
planter sur les pointes
pourquoi avez vous appelez votre nouvel
album empire c'est mal qu'est ce c'est
samsara sellerie matériel en fait c'est
l'empiré lempire du matériel et est
aussi l' empire de l'enfermement dans la
matière
c'est ce que ressent nicolas notamment
dans les enfermements du corps c'est à
dire même fait ça j'ai l'impression que
si vous parlez d une forme de pays
dansiez ou de maisons brevets ce pauvre
voilà pour lui il est toujours dans dans
le sentiment de l'enfermement sont la
planète terre
d'une manière générale dans l'univers
vous avez dû être cher c'est tendu hier
il avait dû être servi pendant le
confinement
bah non parce qu'en fait je suis tout
temps confinés chez moi je sens jamais
chez moi en fait donc donc quelque part
je suis habitué à la prison je me suis
reconstruite en miniature voilà c'est à
dire que nicolas il vit rideaux fermés
dans du rouge argento et il
il est adepte du voyage intérieur le
voyage autour de sa chambre
enfin surtout de l'ennui autour de ma
chambre voilà l'ennui tandis que moi
c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup souffert de
l'enfermement
mais je ne me suis pas laissé faire je
me suis sauvé toutes les nuits mais on
arrive au même résultat puisque lll
c'est un guépard donc elles courent très
très très très vite dans as
ça va ne pourra essayer des les
shoppings gazelle moi j'ai une panthère
sur une branche gazelles qui passent en
dessous des boums
je vous laisse tomber sur elle et
finalement la shop window même à part
moi seul je suis partisan du moindre
effort
donc il ya déjà plusieurs extraits de
cet album sous forme de clips qui sont
sortis avant le confinement pendant le
confinement depuis la fin du confinement
est alors quand on écoute l'album on a
l'impression qu'il est assez parole du
coroner de la crise du corps des virus
ils n'en parlent jamais mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il ne parle que de ça
alors est ce que c'est moi qui suis des
formes et moi qui veut tout voir à la
lumière de du coronavirus ou est ce que
est ce que vous même quand vous leur
écoute et aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez
pas qu'il ya des airs tué désert et même
des textes qui nous parle de cela dans
cette prometic
cette micro bien est ce que j'ai écrit
il ya vraiment j'ai écrit il il ya trois
ans les paroles à 3,82 virus du tout
simplement en général quand on écrit des
choses profondément à zain dans la vie
donc faudrait faut se méfier de ce qu'on
écrit réellement oui c'est à dire que
nicolas toujours un côté chaman et de
vin il écrit ils rêvent les choses elle
arrive et c'est vrai que notre le
premier titre on a mis en ligne qui est
juste come-back alive ça a eu un écho
immédiat chez les gens en se disant oui
c'est la prière on fait tous pour les
gens autour de nous cette planète
entière 4 milliards nous ont confiné et
on demande à tout le monde
just can't back la dhr en fait nicolas
l'a beaucoup entendu dans ces séjours
non sans rire moi voilà vous l'avez
écrit pour vous c'est il a fait une
prière pour lui même juste revient en
ville et et avait tellement de bêtises
que je vais tellement loin dans
l'exploration de la vda délai de la
bêtise qu'il faut bien que alors bon je
vous dise revient quand même envie voilà
je ne dirais pas que c'est tellement la
bêtise c'est plutôt la l'addiction et on
s'est pas une déco lalala l'édiction ses
bêtes
peut-être idiot ou est peut-être n'a
rien de très intelligent mais le
le corps vous dépasse et donc comme on
se sent tous quand même alors c'est mon
esprit qui déborde c'est pas mon corps
voilà mon corps il fait ce qu'il peut
voilà votre corps fait ce qu'il peut
mais souvent ils vous emprisonne et de
manière sinon ils essayent les lignes il
me fous dans la zone mais parce que je
vais trop loin quoi voilà il va trop
loin dans un euro mon corps me censure
voilà et donc vous savez la phrase de
cocteau savoir jusqu'où on peut aller
trop loin
ben lui sait jamais où est la limite et
une l'excès de toujours et il se
retrouve aux urgences des hôpitaux et
des colles shannara des retailles joue
ici ils ont bien sûr on écoutera tout à
l'heure ce come back au live mais
commençons par le le dernier celui qui
vient de sortir c'est le clip de
hamburgers on en regarde tout de suite
un extrait
[Musique]
tard
quatre silhouettes m
m
[Musique]
valeur
tu peux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
les sex-shops avec leurs déguisements et
leurs néons sont des hauts lieux de la
mythologie du rock on les a fermés
pendant le confinement considérant que
ça n'était pas des produits de première
nécessité est ce que vous l'avez
regretté on aurait dû les laisser
ouverts
non en fait on est allé on est à l'ère
on est allé à pigalle un soir et en fait
il y avait absolument aucun ego à part
celui du sexodrome donc on les a un peu
déçu mais il y avait quand même un seul
derrière beaucoup de si j'y aille en
fait parce que c'était impossible à
faire pendant le confinement mais il ya
des oman a besoin un magasin de lingerie
où on a peut justement de lingerie sexy
de la nuit et où on a peu tourné voilà
ces images et me mettre à la place du
mannequin de la vitrine
voilà ça ça peut être fait via il ya
beaucoup de mélancolie dans les combles
de faire des dons siggi à un coude mais
en fait cette chanson je les ai écrites
c'était le jour la démission de jean
marc ayrault c'est authentique
oui en effet ça remonte un peu en tout
cas mauvais s'arrête comme ils veulent
non mais mais c'est vrai que il ya aussi
cette errance cette espèce de
déambulation de l'homme seul face aux
vitrines des sex shops ou regardent
toujours une espèce de sex-shop ses
découpes qui voit réel vous êtes dans un
club c'est armand d un seul bon bah
c'est peut-être des des hommes qui
viennent acheter de la lingerie pour le
saas est décédé dans les et 110 mais
maintenant c'est très bobo c'est un
[ __ ] les mecs qui vont acheter de la
lingerie et de sextoys small arms of qui
choisit quoi bon ben moi en tout cas je
suis allé dans le seul choc qui était
ouvert héééé le monsieur ma part comme
vous êtes une femme vous êtes un homme
seul
voilà il m'a dit mais tu t'appelles
comment tu t'appelles comment je lui dis
qu'on dit j'étais ravi parce qu'il m'a
pas reconnu et je peux acheter tout ce
qu'il fallait dans le sept petites
boutiques des musées
vision mélancolie dans les sex-shops
comme vote dans votre album d'ailleurs
mais est-ce qu'il ya du désir
j'avais trouvé qu'il y avait du désir
vous ah ben moi j'aime bien c'est sûr et
je trouve que la lingerie est super je
crois que nicolas connaît très très bien
et a vous d en plus tous les magasins et
de lingerie c'est quelque chose qu'il
affectionne il ya lille il ya deux ans
j'ai aussi pas cher à belleville chez
givenchy
voilà mes mais de toute façon moi j'aime
tout l'enchantement et j'aime tout la
fantasmagorie autour du désir et de la
sensualité et pigalle c'est connu dans
le monde entier pour être le mieux où il
ya cette espèce d'électricité c'est pour
cela qu'il ya tous ces néons qui crépite
l'électricité du désign et andré hallé a
emboîté surgissent et donc le lieu en
bulgarie c'est aussi l'homme qui rasent
un peu les murs
c'est comme ça que je l'imaginent et qui
n'ose y installer dans ce secteur voilà
vraiment pas ça il y en a beaucoup qui
ne pas vous mais elle a beaucoup qui
n'osent pas y aller même si l'on rêve
d'intégration des textes moi j'ai
toujours dit sable et la table qui le
forfait dans un spin off
vous parlez du monde entier il se trouve
que ariel vous êtes né aux états unis
mais vous avez grandi au mexique nicolas
claire et nette nomme penh au cambodge
et il ya grandi jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
obligé de repartir en catastrophe en
1975 ou à peu près
certains s'étonnent que vous vous soyez
rencontrer tous les deux comment
l'expliquez vous rétrospectivement parce
que 20 ans vous avez déjà fait c'est
votre deuxième album vous avez même fait
un film ensemble
le comment expliquez-vous
rétrospectivement votre rencontre
disons la saison déjà les voir
j'écoutais je sais pas moi jean 20 et
shane le velvet lécureux des trucs c'est
le moment où que j'allais voir les
pierrot le fou les trucs comme ça c'est
les bergman c'est sévère 16 ans et là où
le goût se fixe un peu quoi et il se
trouve que parmi ces oeuvres que
j'allais voir et revoir qui m'intriguait
il y avait les pyramides bleues de
l'open le film que vous avez réalisé une
claire année car il est très jeune et
moi j'allais voir à 16 ans ça fait
partie de ma démarche de dire mishima de
dire cocteau de lire proust d'aller voir
les pyramides bleues d'écouté pour nos
graphiques et d'écouté du réduit jeune
extra voilà et en fait je me suis
rappelé uniquement la renvoyer en trente
ans plus tard alors ce qu'est ce qui est
merveilleux c'est que quand on s'est
rencontré il ya tout de suite eu une
conversation sur pinceau ligny et les
éléphants et la conversation n'a jamais
cessé et on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
toute une convergence de goût et de
dégoût d'ailleurs très sûr est de 2000
comment dire mais le paysage mais il
cosmos qui nous rassemble et même si on
était deux êtres totalement antagonistes
d'une certaine manière on pourrait dire
aussi que vous êtes tels que vous êtes
complémentaire au fond l'une et est une
vedette de de lover ground et vous
nicolas becker plutôt une vedette de
l'underground
au fond vous chacun apporte de l'eau à
l'autre ce qui lui mangent way où il a
peut-être c'est ça en tout cas
mais c'est pas vraiment une spice a valu
stratégie commerciale comme sa base en
bas le marché du monde depuis 38 ans en
hamac et donc non ingérence et aimait
mon dos des parents soyez
en tant qu'ami on n'a jamais même pensé
à faire un disque ensemble en fait ça
peut faire à mesure mais parra par des
concours de circonstances ce qu'ils sont
qui trouvent qu'elle a écrite et
deviennent plus de la coïncidence que de
la coïncidence mais voyez ce 60ème même
pas passé par la tête alors vous auriez
tout le temps de décrire un album mais
le fait est que c'est un peu comme les
rencontres de dada des années vingt du
19e siècle c'est à dire que les arts
s'interpénètrent se recompose c'est
comme des systèmes sanguin qui se
trouvent et et les choses paraissent
évidentes
voilà donc on s'est pas posé de
questions et on est tous les deux très
warholiens / / / sur ce plan là c'est la
phrase just do it est quelque chose qui
moi me parle beaucoup c'est une de mes
phrases fondatrice donc on fait les
choses encore en ministre inge mariage
ce qu'il faisait avec toi non je trouve
pas aussi tout de même enfin bon de
toute façon le velvet underground c'est
un des 1 un des piliers majeurs
c'est bon vous préférez voilà c'est le
groupe préféré de nicolas et il m'a fait
aussi connaître moi je ne connaissais
pas johnny dvg je connais je connaissais
pas bien mieux mais de piau mais robert
smith je connaissais localiser sa tête
c'est tout voilà je connaissais quelques
quelques gros tubes mais pas vraiment
tout le parcours et puis arrive berline
et puis heureusement qu'on ne connaît
pas tous mais pas tellement dramatique
déjà je m'ennuie tellement ben voilà il
m'a fait connaître aussi d'aider tout un
pan du cinéma fantastique que j'ai a do
ré et des films d'horreur très très
sophistiqué vous avez encore des chances
doit être au début moi j' ai tous eus et
y aller plus loin on va regarder le pays
on va on va regarder un extrait de du
deuxième clip qui est sortie pendant le
confinement celui là celui là c'est
grand hôtel
on le regarde tout de suite
qui sont ils
bien
qui sait
oui
[Musique]
dit non
ça
feed ans
[Musique]
et
ces choses ne changent pas
et je fus
[Musique]
et
c'est chaud
[Musique]
je
les chiens
[Musique]
maingain
monsieur
[Musique]
je
le grand hôtel aussi c'est dans la
mythologie du rock si chère à nicolas
car normalement on détruit la chambre
d'hôtel dans une espèce de passage
obligé vous êtes très respectueux je
croyais avoir reconnu le l'hôtel saint
james qui se trouve dans le 16e
arrondissement et que sa décoration très
particulière néanmoins quand on voit ce
clip et quand on entend cette chance on
a l'impression qu'ils vont disparaître
les grands hôtels que vous avez l'air de
redouter ce même si j'ai il s'agit
l'univers en fait c'est en fait l'hôtel
le texte une métaphore pour prendre des
chambres et des couloirs infinie et on
refait toujours les mêmes idioties aux
travaux même porte on se perd on sait
plus sur un tourne à droite tantôt à
gauche espère en vain une sortie
officielle en vain au sait-on jamais
mais c'est à dire c'est vraiment comme
nicolas à nouveau c'est une sorte de
métaphore de l'univers avec une sorte
d'éternel retour on tape toujours aux
mêmes portes ans on fera tache toujours
sur les mêmes choses mais moi surtout ce
labyrinthe un labyrinthe mais moi c'est
un outil bien voilà moi je dois dire que
j'adore les grands hôtels et j'aime
cette idée de de la décadence dans le
fait qu'il y a tous ces fantômes qui ont
vécu dans les couloirs qui sont placés
dans un chenil gariel cependant le shine
et p&p chaque chaque chaque chambre à
son secret il ya tellement de gens qui
se sont aimés passionnément
et puis les grands hôtels ou les hôtels
tout court
c'est aussi les hôtels des rendez vous
c'est l'amour donc ça c'est de la
vaucelle ses balles grand hôtel on peut
aussi en opérant des poids lourds dans
les comptes rien aujourd'hui
et puis alors on en arrive on vient on
en arrive au premier clip qui était
sorti joes come back alive vous y
faisiez allusion tout à l'heure alors là
c'est plutôt les ruines l'apocalypse la
destruction la table rase on ne regarde
tout de suite un extrait à la fois c'est
l'histoire suit
forte anomalie
à peu près à mi voix
quand
[Musique]
mais moi
d'accord
[Musique]
je fuis
mais
[Musique]
voilà vous anderson vous admettre
ressorti vivant et du clip et de cet
album et du coronavirus absolument et
alors ce qui est beau dans joe's come
back au live c'est cette idée de revenir
vraiment vivant est la loi qui personnes
la moitié de ma vie en hôpital voilà
alors nicolas et les urgences des
hôpitaux des hôpitaux ça vraiment et
koné pour frêche préfère un trip advisor
à noter les meilleurs urgence urgence de
paris et donc c'est vrai que tout ça a
inspiré tout tout tout cet imaginaire
mais au fond on a l'impression que le
rock c'est vrai qu'au début ça tu es pas
mal de gens jeunes en général il ya
beaucoup de héros du rock qui sont morts
accident de voiture drogue avec des avec
des revolvers aussi mais au fond passer
cette épreuve qui quand on est à 1 sec
ça conserve plus tôt on a l'impression
qu'au fond il y en a assez peu qui sont
morts on a l'impression que les gens du
jour est toujours une fois qu'ils ont
passé le cap fixé à la facilité d'une
fois qu'ils ont passés de cap fatidique
des 27 euros il ay ay continuer leur
connerie mais vers la 50 à nice calme
même gun's n'roses
hmm hmm hmm les clous maintenant ils
sont les souks chine et ben alors il
faut espérer que de bas mais je suis en
train d'essayer de nommer merklin
complètement parce que je sens que sinon
voilà là mon corps il commence à présent
d'être morflé plus l'agent réellement
nicolas aurait dû mourir à 27 ans comme
amy winehouse et generation la rondeur
sa loge voilà mais il a des sortes de
forces vives
incroyable qui fait que même quand il
est vraiment vraiment vraiment
borderline il ressurgit et je trouve que
c'est aussi la beauté de nicolas c'est
cette vérité du rockeur de cette vérité
de héros au tragique
en fait les retraduite mecs ne sont pas
dans le fait
maintenant on vit dans une telle époque
où tout est fait que ou d'aider des gens
se jettent sur un canapé avec une bière
à la main en jouant les rockeurs et qui
ne sont pas des rockers parce que le
rocker c'est une figure et c'est avec un
canapé une bière à la main en sang mais
partout si vous voulez vraiment stupide
pour faire un oui vous préférez une
bonne bien bien caché dans la portion
congrue peu partout bon mais mais mais
il est vrai que c'est cette cette idée
du no limit cette idée de l'excès cette
idée du romantisme noir
c'est pour ça que le l'album est inspiré
de ses figures du rock qui sont encore
vivants et merveilleuse comme nikkei que
nous adorons tous les deux et sur
lesquels on y pleure ou pleurent en
l'écoutant la musique et c'est l'émotion
et ses essais ça se veut je pense que
nicolas et l'écrivain qui écrit aussi de
manière métaphysique toutes les paroles
ont toujours un sens c'est malin je me
suis sûr qu'ils vont dire lequel nicolas
ker vous portez toujours je sais pas si
c'est un foulard ou une cravate en soie
noir autour du cou sur grange de qui ou
de quoi vous portiez le deuil
non en fait c'est un ruban de deux
cadeaux de noël
ah oui vous avez dû le recevoir il y
avait très longtemps je vais toujours vu
avec ça mais non mais non en fait je
peux rien quand on va dans une boutique
elle complète de rubans de cadeaux de
noël voilà les apporte donc je pense que
des rubans de pour faire des cadeaux aux
fêtes s'est jamais le même en fruits
parce que un jour autour de l'arbre de
noël il y là il a il a piqué tous les
rubans et ça lui allait très bien donc
il est resté voilà avec le ruban du
paquet mais souvent le ruban du parquet
même plus beaucoup le paquet donc moi je
trouve que c'est très bien de porter un
ruban bercy
arielle dombasle merci nicolas ker je
rappelle que votre nouvel album en
firent sorte demain 19 juin il vous
serez en concert à la maroquinerie le 17
septembre
on se retrouve juste après une pause
avec pierre curie et les oeuvres du
célèbre patron anglais william turner
[Musique]
je reçois maintenant pierre curie le
conservateur du musée jacquemart andré à
paris je le reçois en duplex comme
arielle dombasle et nicolas ker j'ai dit
par skype mais non c'est en duplex le
musée jacquemart-andré ou où se tient
l'exposition turner dont l'ouverture et
la fermeture ont été reculés c'est
jusqu'au 11 janvier bonjour pierre curie
leur william turner est né en 1775 il
est mort en 1851
beaucoup voient en ce grand peintre de
paysages époustouflants un ancêtre des
des impressionnistes est ce que c'est
votre cas pas vraiment c'est un peu un
malentendu sur l'histoire de turner
parce que les impressionnistes notamment
les français qui sont allés à londres
après 1870 171 n'ont pas vu le turner
que nous montrons aujourd'hui ils ont vu
les grands tableaux historiques ils ont
vu la bataille de waterloo qui est à la
royal academy ou d'autres votre oeuvre
un peu je dirais pompiers de de turner
parce qu'il a une double une double
carrière
c'est un peu au contraire le regard que
les historiens d'art ont eu à la fin du
19e siècle sur l'impressionnisme qui ce
regard a fait regarder autrement
l'oeuvre de turner mais c'était une
oeuvre entièrement dissimulées dans des
cartons tout les aquarelles qui peuvent
pas faire penser qu'on est là à l'aube
de l'impressionnisme étaient des oeuvres
secrète des oeuvres privées en fait
alors parmi les oeuvres qu'on va montrer
elles figurent toutes dans votre
catalogue elle ne figure pas tout dans
l'exposition
néanmoins d'autres voient dans tourneur
l'ancêtre de l'art abstrait alors qu'est
ce qu'il en est
d'après vous aussi c'est toujours assez
facile de faire l'histoire de façon
rétrospective en effet turner parfois
confiné à l'abstraction dans ses oeuvres
les plus les plus personnels les plus
expérimentales qui étaient des oeuvres
qu'il peignait des aquarelles
précisément qu'il peignait comme il l'a
dit pour son propre plaisir formation de
pleasure et et donc il posait ses crânes
beginning ses ébauches coloré et les
jetaient en quelque sorte sur les
feuilles de façon presque est ce que ça
lui provoque des sentiments de
reconstitution des ambiances colorées
qui l'avait vu dans des paysages et en
cela il n'est pas complètement éloigné
de certains artistes asiatiques comme un
rookie ou d'autres mais ces oeuvres là
n'étaient pas publiques lassées fera
pense que oui oui hier moi c'est
exactement ça oui oui c'est vrai
ce sont des espèces de je dirais presque
d'expérimentation pour montrer ses
sentiments en fait
turner est un romantique c'est quelqu'un
qui recherche des sensations avec
l'arrêt qui cherchent à l'est à les
transmettre
donc il ya ce geste est à 7 gestualité
dans sa peinture elle est très présente
dans les aquarelles était également
présente dans ses huiles et c'est
pourquoi aussi nous avons voulu
présenter ses différents aspects de
turner qui est un peu docteur jekyll et
mr hyde il a une carrière officielle il
peint quelquefois des aquarelles ou des
huiles extrêmement réaliste très très
fini très très valable aussi et puis il
crée des dizaines des milliers d'oeuvres
graphiques beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
libre beaucoup plus abstraite et c'est
vrai que notre regard du 20e ou du 21e
siècle sur ses oeuvres là peut faire des
rapports avec ce qui s'est passé en
effet disons avec l'abstraction
gestuelle avec l'abstraction lyrique à
partir des années 1950 en europe et en
amérique il se trouve que kutcher n'a
d'ailleurs est resté très peu connu en
france jusqu'aux années 80 quasiment un
cas il ya 40 ans il ya une grande
rétrospective turner
en 82 ou 83 au grand palais et beaucoup
de français découvrent turner à ce
moment là oui cette relative
méconnaissance de turner elle tient un
peu enfin tient à de nombreux facteurs
mais il est vrai que comme donneur de
son vivant a vendus essentiellement des
oeuvres au château châtelain anglais ou
à la grande aristocratie anglaise ou
alors à des institutions comme la royal
academy ou la national gallery et c'est
énorme legs qu'il fait à la nation
anglaise et bien il est rentré dans des
dents dans le seul musée anglais
aujourd'hui qui le concerne pratiquement
la totalité de son oeuvre
c'est à dire la tête galerie donc ses
dix neuf mille ou 25000 aquarelles selon
qu'on compte les carnets enfin
différents systèmes ses oeuvres sont
entièrement conservé à londres beaucoup
de châteaux anglais possèdent et
concerne encore des détourneurs les
musées anglais les musées américains qui
ont pu en acheter aussi au 19e siècle
mais la france est restée très à l'écart
le continent si je puis dire est resté
très à l'écart de cette passion en
anglais anglo saxon pour turner qui de
son vivant a été considéré comme un des
plus grands peintres de son temps alors
c'est ces jeux les listes à grands
peintres du paysage on en voit
d'ailleurs défilé derrière moi au moment
où nous parlons
commandez le paysage parce que pendant
très très longtemps on ne va pas dire
que des animaux d'abord dans les grottes
de lascaux on prend pratique pour pas
d'homme et puis ensuite on va peindre
des hommes mais pas de paysages et puis
enfants ou alors des paysages derrière
les hommes et puis à un moment le
paysage l'emportent sur l'homme pas chez
tous les peintres bien entendu mais chez
un certain nombre d'entre eux comment ça
se passe sur une petite révolution au
moment de se mettre à peindre un paysage
où il n'y a pas d'homme
l'ours est arrivé aventure nerfs mais
mais c'est arrivé dans quelles
circonstances dans quelles conditions
s'est quand même à l'époque de turner
justement que cette révolution se
produit le paysage existant le paysage
pur le paysage sans personnages existent
depuis la fin du xvème siècle on a un
exemple très précoce chez gérard david à
bruges
mais en réalité c'est surtout au 16e et
au xviie siècle qui s'est développée
dans le cadre d'une nomenclature
académique qui était le paysage
historique donc le paysage historique
par pur le plus pur c'est celui de pouce
à ou celui de claude gellée tellement
aimé des anglais est d'ailleurs
collectionnés par les anglais il a
beaucoup influencé turner c'est à
l'époque de turner ou la recherche du
sublime va passer en quelque sorte avant
la description de l'anecdote fut-elle
history et donc on argue le glissement
progressif dans as vraiment à la fin du
xviiie siècle et au début du 19ème vers
ce paysage sublime qui s'inspire de plus
en plus de la nature
alors d'abord tourner harry il s'est
intéressé à l architecture et il ya
beaucoup de dessins de croquis de
peinture même on voit bien que celle
architecture qui l'intéressent plus qui
est devant le paysage parfois même n'y a
pas de paysages du tout il n'y a que de
l' architecture oui alors il a commencé
sa carrière en effet il l'a commencé
très jeune il avait 13 13 14 ans quand
il a produit ses premières oeuvres est
assez vite il travaille pour des
architectes ou des cabinets
d'architectes à l'ordre qui avaient
besoin d'artistes représentant tout
simplement les bâtiments qu'il se
proposait de construire
et puis de ses commandes très spécifique
de commandes de d'architecte il est
passé aussi à des commandes de
propriétaires terriens d'aristocrates
qui voulait en quelque sorte des
portraits de leurs châteaux ou de leurs
somptueuses propriétés dans le kent dans
les environs de londres alors il a passé
château on en a plusieurs magnifiques
exemples à l'expo dans l'exposition
et puis peu à peu il a installé ses
châteaux dans des dents des grands
paysages romantiques parce que
terre-neuve c'est un romantique et puis
peu à peu le château s'efface en quelque
sorte et nous présentons des aquarelles
extrêmement impressionnante où le
château les châteaux de vienne l'espèce
de silhouettes en négatif comme des
fantômes de châteaux alors que tout tout
tout la nature l'air le vent les nuages
tout ça est décrit avec une emphase
extraordinaire est l'objet du l'objet de
l'aquarelle est presque 10 ou en fait
dans l'atmosphère est effectivement et
puis au bout d'un moment d'ailleurs la
silhouette du château qu'on voit encore
derrière moi va disparaître elle aussi
est il ne restera plus que le paysage
est évidemment il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de tableaux de de turner ne
représentant que des paysages qui figure
dans votre exposition c'est à vous de
vous dire c'est un romantique alors à
quoi on reconnaît un romantique en
peinture je dirais que le les artistes
romantiques mais en littérature c'est un
peu la même chose recherche l'expression
d'un sentiment et surtout des sentiments
qui dépasse un peu en quelque sorte la
nature humaine et il est sûr que cet
anglais qui vivait à londres dans un
territoire quand même extrêmement plat
ne peut être que frappé par les paysages
des alpes par les environs du lac de
genève par les paysages d'italie je
dirais une emphase dans tous ces
paysages qui est extraordinaire et qui
emporte son adhésion et l'artiste
évidemment représentent des sites mais
il représente surtout finalement le les
sentiments les impressions qu'il a
ressentie devant ces sites est il il ya
quelque chose qu'il faut vraiment
mentionner aussi à notre public c'est
que turner travail en atelier les
aquarelles et les huiles sont pas à
londres dans l'atelier est en réalité il
a une mémoire visuelle absolument
prodigieuse lorsqu'il se promène dans
les alpes ou en italie il fait qu'elle
prend quelques notes dans des cars
veille fait des petits dessins mais
c'est vraiment dans son atelier à
londres qu'il va ré imaginer ses
lumières extraordinaire cette profondeur
c'est à ces atmosphères dans ces
paysages absolument grandiose
donc il ya une dimension très
personnelle une dimension poétique de
reconstruction qui est vraiment là je
pense la marque d'un artiste romantique
un artiste qui est qui qui en fait
marcher son âme en fait on a dit que l'
architecture avait disparu au profit du
paysage seul mais on a l'impression qu'à
partir d'un moment le paysage seul
disparaît derrière les éléments au fond
ce que peinture nord ce sont les
éléments le soleil la pluie la tempête
ça c'est hoerner oui absolument est ce
qui l'intéresse c'est pas l'anecdote de
la tempête c'est là sa force c'est son
sa capacité à dominer l'homme en fait
très vieux à la fin de sa vie un de ses
derniers voyages c'est de venir en
france en normandie où il veut voir de
belles tempête on sent l'homme qui
recherchent des sensations en fait et
nous avons accroché dans la dernière
salle de l'exposition deux huiles
extraordinaires qui sont des tableaux
alors pour le coup qui relève de
l'abstraction gestuelle avec où l'on
sent les mois une sorte de mouvement
giratoire du bras du peintre de la main
du pape qui jette sa peinture qui la
projette qu'il la gratte avec une espèce
de véhémence pour je pense retrouver
cette violence qu'il a ressenti en
observant les éléments il est célèbre
pour ses grandes toiles turner celle ci
je croyais très grande d'ailleurs celle
qui est derrière moi il y en a beaucoup
de beaucoup plus petit dans cette
exposition c'est rare on l'est on les
connaît moins bien ses oeuvres je dirais
à taille humaine ou quoi oui alors là ça
se rejoint ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur le sur le 2 le double turner
le turner publique qui a une carrière
académique absolument officiel c'est un
c'était un artiste très célèbres de son
temps il
il vendait bien il exposé il avait sa
propre galerie à partir de 1840 la
turner gallery à londres qui était sa
propre magasin quelque sorte vous
présentez et vendez
ses oeuvres il il participait à toutes
les expositions de la deûle de la royal
academy dont il était membre des
professeurs de perspectives à la royal
academy il ya même dirigé un moment là
l'académie c'est dire si c'est un
peintre officiel on ne peut plus
académique mais ces oeuvres plus petit
que nous présentons en assez grand
nombre à jacquemart-andré elles sont sa
production personnelle ce qui l'a gardé
pour lui alors le moindre morceau de
papier l'on voit derrière vous la dd
décaller beginning avec des tempêtes
ces impressions alors là c'est là qu'on
est peut-être en effet à l'aube d'un
certaine impressionnisme il les a gardés
pour lui les a gardés précieusement
je t'ai pas le moindre moindre la
moindre improvisation à l'aquarelle
étaient conservés en carton c'est
pourquoi lorsqu il lègue à la nation
anglaise en 1851 son atelier on va
trouver ces je ne sais pas on va dire à
peu près vingt ou vingt-cinq mille
oeuvres graphiques
c'est aussi un artiste qui a beaucoup
travaillé pour l'édition et les voyages
notamment qui sont très à la mode il
illustre des recueils de poèmes mais
aussi des appels en france les voyages
pittoresques
donc il a voyagé le long de la seine le
long de la loire et ses petites
aquarelles de petit format sont
transposées par des graffeurs
professionnels pour être publiés dans
des livres c'est un c'est un très grand
aquarelliste il a fait évidemment de
très beaux tableaux à l'huile mais ont
ils à une utilisation de l'aquarelle qui
semble assez singulière très personnel
oui c'est un c'est un technicien
absolument virtuose est très jeune il
est virtuose on voit on voit dans
l'exposition des oeuvres d'art autour de
la vingtaine et on voit aussi tout le
soin qu'il apporte est assez grande
aquarelles notamment en observant les
bordes et des papiers on voit le nombre
de fois qu'il les a reprises recoller
sur leur support décoller recoller
décoller qui montre une sorte
d'acharnement en fait
technique mais très vite il a totalement
maîtrisé cette technique était à la mode
mais ses contemporains considéré turner
comme le prince de le prince de
l'aquarelle et il ya une virtuosité
extraordinaire dans les offres que nous
présentons notamment dans l'es22
première salle et on se rend compte
oui on voit derrière les halles
merveilleux paysages dans l'hérault à
chamonix x et c'est une oeuvre qui l'a
pas voilà et il l'a peinte à londres
c'est extraordinaire on al impression qu
un peu comme corot il allait devant le
motif avec sa palette mais c'est pas du
tout le cas ils reconstituent est tous
et tous ces paysages dans sont dans dans
sa tête dans son mental et
en hiver à londres vous l'avais dit
c'était un grand voyageur enfin à
l'époque d'être un grand voyageur se
voulait dire aller en france et en
italie
il va beaucoup en normandie vous l'a dit
pour voir de belles tempête mais il faut
bien voir que là aussi va être
précurseur des impressionnistes qui eux
viendront très nombreux ensuite peindre
la normandie lui il est là avant tout
comme d'autres peintres anglais
d'ailleurs la normandière elle
impressionne toujours passionné les
peintres à la fois parce qu'il ya des
tempêtes mais aussi j'ai l'impression
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'eau il ya une
lumière particulière
quel est votre avis là-dessus pourquoi
la normandie attire-t-elle à ce point
oui du point de vue des parisiens c'est
évidemment l'invention du train et nous
la ligne de chemin de fer qui très vite
est parti vers rouen et vers la mer et
d'ailleurs je rappelle que turner est un
des tout premiers à représenter une
locomotive dans un tableau 1 et bon ça
c'est tintin c'est un tableau qui est à
la national gallery je pense que pour
pour les anglais en effet c'était sans
doute le le pays le plus facile celui
qui ressemble le plus à l'angleterre
aussi
qui était évidemment de l'autre côté du
channel très très facile et pratique
d'accès c'est presque un peu une
angleterre bis un peu comme le comme
l'aquitaine
donc c'est une vieille tradition en fait
des anglais en normandie et peut-être
qu'il faut faire remonter sa guillaume
le conquérant je ne sais pas il ya la
vieille tradition aussi qui consiste
pour les anglais à faire le grand tour
en italie
et à venise il y as rome dans l'univers
de turner c'est drôle parce qu'à cette
époque-là l'italie sur le plan pictural
n'est plus aussi extraordinaire qu'elle
l'était du temps de la renaissance
qu'est-ce qui va chercher en italie
thurnherr en réalité c'est vrai que le
grand tour était encore tout à fait à la
mode à son époque
c'est un peu un prétexte on va en italie
pour voir les antiques les monuments de
la rome antique
mais très vite les artistes de cette
époque regarde les paysages regard-là
lieu la merveilleuse lumière italienne
on peut faire un parallèle avec
corrosion les coraux part aussi en
italie et peint des paysages
relativement banal son monument
particulier il avec une tout autre
approche du paysage c'est
particulièrement sensible dans cette ce
tableau que nous avons à paris qui est
le lac de nesmy où on voit un turner
très violent avec des couleurs presque
là de la croix des rouges des bleus avec
une approche très différente de ce que
corot a pu peindre en italie mais oui il
ya un abandon un peu du sujet romain les
les temples et ruine les colonnes tout
ça m'intéresse beaucoup moins vous
parliez de sa galerie c'est vrai que
tourneur ouvre sa propre galerie au tout
début du 19e siècle
on va l'avoir d'ailleurs elle est là
c'est elle c'est la galerie de turner
c'est très anglais ça on a le droit
d'être commerçant qu'on soit un
aristocrate ou qu'on soit un peintre on
a le droit de faire du commerce pourra
français pour les france est il
imaginable
et quand on est aristocrate et quand on
est peintre oui oui il y avait un
système de galeries beaucoup plus rigide
finalement en france
c'est vrai que les aristocrates français
considéré qu'il n'avait absolument pas
le droit de travailler où ce ne se
donnait pas cette liberté
il ya quelque chose d'assez modern dance
et dans cet homme qui a une personnalité
tout à fait particulière néanmoins qui a
été bien illustré je dirais bien
souligné dans le lit dans le film de
mike leigh en 2014
avec cette performance incroyable de
timothy spall dans le rôle du peintre
qui lui a valu d'ailleurs le prix
d'interprétation à cannes et original et
combo le film et de personnes valence et
l'odeur aurait pu concéder est un
original c'est le nom original comme que
beaucoup d'anglais comme beaucoup
beaucoup d'anglais oui ils sont
originaux à nos yeux
justement on ne connait enfin moi je ne
connais qu'un autoportrait de turner il
est assez jeune il doit avoir 25 ans
est-ce que d'abord expliquer ce qu'il y
en a d'autres que celui que j'ai sous
derrière moi et qu'est ce que l'on sait
de sa vie je n'ai pas vu le film de mike
leigh
est-ce qu'ils étaient mariés ce qu'il
était heureux est-ce qu'il était
tourmenté
pioneer comment était-il alors 7e
porterez à ma connaissance le seul
autoportrait la figure la pas
l'intéressé puis il ya une organisation
du marché de l'art en quelque sorte en
angleterre à cette époque qui est
extrêmement fière archi c est rigoureuse
vous allez les portraitistes les
paysagistes les peintres d'histoire il
ya vraiment une spécialisation des
artistes lui s'est très vite au
spécialisé sur le paysage et et n'a pas
n'a pas abordé la question du portrait
et donc de l'autoportrait ce qu'on sait
de lui dont on a pas mal de témoignages
quand même on a de la correspondance des
témoignages c'était un homme très je
dirais assez infréquentable de mauvais
caractère misogyne vous gonfle on le
décrit vraiment comme une personne très
trêve va brut
il était à l'académie mais il parlait le
slang il avait un accent cockney est
très marquée et sa vie privée est assez
curieuse puisqu'il un moment il est avec
une dame qui s'appelle mi6 doute il va
se faire appeler mr doute il veut plus
qu'on l'appelle turner et cette dame a
deux filles qui sont peut-être les
filles du père de turner donc c'était un
peu un peu compliqué et d'ailleurs son
père le père de turner était son
assistant
il est c'est lui qui préparait les
couleurs les papiers les pinceaux il a
été l'assistante de son fils jusqu'à
jusqu'à sa mort c'est plutôt mignon ça
fait beaucoup aujourd'hui des pères qui
deviennent les assistants deux de leurs
enfants joueur de tennis ou pourquoi pas
voilà bah disons qu'il était il était
déjà très très moderne pour ça
voilà votre exposition dure jusqu'au 11
janvier elle a été reculée puisque
l'ouverture a été reculé alors j'imagine
que l'on va pas l'exposition turgeman
mer au musée jacquemart-andré comme on y
allait avant est ce qu'il ya des
précautions à prendre
alors les précautions en la première
précaution à prendre c'est de prendre
une réservation
parce qu'en ce moment les entrées ne se
font que sur
sur réservation alors ça peut paraître
très restrictif mais alors ça
j'encourage vraiment les gens à venir en
ce moment parce que comme nous avons une
jauge de trèbes badens nombreux
visiteurs bas les ya peu de monde dans
les salles et c'est vraiment le meilleur
moment pour voir les oeuvres
tranquillement avec peu de public
et puis bien sûr le chaque visiteur est
invité à porter un masque pendant
pendant sa visite
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
musées ne se ressemblent plus y compris
un petit musée entre guillemets comme
jacquemart-andré où normalement il ya
toujours beaucoup de monde là c'est vrai
qu'on peut voir les oeuvres commandes
comme on les voit jamais comme on ne les
voit plus jamais en effet je vais je
fais partie des rares privilégiés qui
peuvent les voir dans ces bonnes
conditions dans le cadre de mon métier
mais c'est vrai que nous avons souvent
beaucoup trop de monde alors c'est la
rançon du succès les salles d'exposition
du musée jacquemart-andré sont installés
dans l'ancien appartement du
conservateur ce qui est aussi un
avantage parce qu'elles ont ces
proportion d'appartements privés
elles permettent donc d'apprécier des
hommes de format modeste de petit format
dans je dirais dans des volumes dans des
espaces qui sont qui sont faites pour
elle ces petites aquarelles petites ou
moyennes aquarelles de turner elle
serait complètement perdu dans des
espaces type d'une grand palais où enfin
il faudrait vraiment restreint de
laisser ses volumes alors que chez nous
elles sont je dirais comme football
elles sont tout à fait comme il faut
tornare si vous deviez le qualifiez vous
qui vivez au milieu des turner depuis un
certain temps maintenant si vous deviez
le qualifié d' un ou deux adjectifs ce
serait quoi
en deux adjectifs
qu'est ce que c'est grâce à jong il
arrivé pour nous alors il est génial
comme peintre et ils n'ouvrent il ouvre
l'espace en fait c'est quelqu'un qui par
ses petits paysages et petit poucet
grands paysages vous projette dans
l'espace c'est pas pour rien qu'il était
professeur de perspectives il a une
maîtrise comme ça deux des trois
dimensions d'une certaine façon mais
toute façon extrêmement atmosphérique
vous rentrez dans une dans un espace
pictural qui est complètement magique et
c'est d'ailleurs me
beaucoup de visiteurs me témoignent de
cette fascination qu'ils ont pour sa
capacité à nous nous aspirer en quelque
sorte dans son univers merci pierre
curie l'exposition turner se tient au
musée jacquemart-andré jusqu'au 11
janvier et non pas ce que dit la fiche
qui est l affiche d'avant le confinement
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]